こんにちは はじめしゃちょー です。
はい
と、今日はですね、
僕ではないんだけど、友達の誕生日でございます。
他の部屋で遊んでいるんですけども、
あのね、
まあね、ちょっとね
マジでバレたくね～
ぜって～バレたくね～
ぜって～バレたくねな
静かな声でやりましょう
ちょっと、ほんとにバレたくないので
なにかと、お世話になってる友達なので、
正常にサプライズをしたいんですよ
僕はね
ほんとにちょっと、そいつにはマジ、いろいろお世話になってるから
ちょっとね、まあスペシャルを感じてもらいたいんですよ。
クラッカーを100個準備しました。
これを、1個ずつパンパンやってもさすがに面白くないすよ。
なので、今回ですね
この洗濯ものカゴの、
この穴ですね
この穴に、クラッカーを1本ずつさしていきます。
こう
どうせ、どうせ伸ばすして1本ずつさしていきます。
いいんじゃない
こういう感じでね
で、全部さした後にこの動線を全部結んで、
ヒモで、うまいことこう結んで一本の太い動線にします。
で、それを引っ張れば100発が
バーン!とバーン!と
出るわけでございます。
いや、もう感動して泣くよ
というわけで、クラッカーをさしていきましょう。
よし
よし、ひとまず全部さしました。
こんな感じでございます。
はい、ここからなんですけども
中の動線をつなぐ作業に入ります。
ちょっと、細かいので、わけわかんないかもしれませんが、これの線を1つにまとめます
なるべくがんばってみま～す
よし
2つずつペアを作っていくんだよ
作戦としては
2人1組でペアを作っていきます。
はぁ～
待て、
しんどいわ～
俺なんでこんなことしているの?
OK
どうでしょうか
ひとまず、全部結び終えました
完璧です。
バッチリだな
結び目のクイッてなっているところを、糸でとうして
ひとまず、ひとまとめにしていきます。
よし
いや、とうしていきましょう。
もう、俺やばいよ～
もう、業者じゃん
ただ、これは性個数か分かんないだよね
でも今4本の線にまとめたんですよ
全部の線を
更に、1つにまとめます。
(1.2.3)
あ～5本か～
あ～ごめんなさい、5本だった
どうだ
こういう感じだ
ここです
ここ
これがもう全部の動線につながっています。
全部揺れてるよね
すべてが1つの動線にまとまったので、
じゃあ、早速もうお友達の誕生日ということで、
クラッカー100発を一気に打ち上げて幸せな誕生日をお迎えしてあげましょう。
では、行こう
まじでうまく行ってほしい
もうすぐで、部屋に来るので
ちょっと、一か八かなんですけど、決めてみようと思います。
(ドアが開く音)
えっ!
おめでとう!!
あ、やべ
(クラッカーの発射音)
あれ?
おめでとう!!
ありがとう!!
えっ、これを準備していたの?
うん
ほんとに?
ほんと
嘘でしょ!?
1時間ぐらいかかっちゃった
ほんとに!?
以上!
【はじめ】ケーキとかもらったからさ
【友達】ありがとう